you're the only one I can count you out
live all right what up guys what up
everybody its Anna Mack here with goes
in and our boys soul maka and in this
week's live stream Saturday stream we're
going to be talking talking about Code
Geass the new HD TV so we decided
because we have so much to talk about so
many theories so many things going on
with this PV now with the new details
that we get from the HD version I
thought we would switch it back up to
the discussion mode so we can really
talk about the series you guys involved
in the chat I've got a bunch of people
emailing me already about various
theories that they have that some stuff
that I didn't even think of so I thought
that rather than doing the rewatching
we'll go back to this format at least
now because we definitely have enough
material to discuss so welcome guys get
settled in in the chat it's gonna be a
cool time what up goes and how you doing
today my friend also brother Rosen okay
I'm doing good me and Anna Mac were just
doing some slava serbian celebration
related stuff and now we're ready for
you guys to talk about this new PV which
as you can tell the internet is excited
about which is cool for us too and soul
maka how you doing man yeah man I'm good
I'm good it's good to be back again on a
Saturday spend a little while I almost
forgot what it was like but yeah it's
good to be here again
bottles yeah because we did we didn't
have much news and then so then we were
just doing the rewatch as however
because we're using OBS I have no idea
how to get guests on re-watch so
technically I don't know how to do that
oh like I don't know if it's possible it
might be but I'm just not sure I was
just watched source reading some of our
comments for the attack on Titan
livestream and some guys like next
episode 24 hours earlier yeah yeah
cuz we left off at a very interesting
point and that's a con Titan and we got
so many peeps in the chat already a by
the way discord party this weekend
we have eNOS birthday today and author
whose birthday tomorrow happy birthday
ladies and the discord part is going to
be happening all Sunday so yeah if
you're not on this core link is in the
description be sure to join us is gonna
be a crazy time in the chat we have
cootie Gohan again
what's up cootie Otaru supreme Oscar
colonel not NIC racists a lot of usual
suspects all marques in the chat foxy
and I see him on Twitter all the time
Lacey Chan creep Ellen Anana is here not
always here yeah Jeremiah Gottwald
oMG Coonan is here that's amazing Luna
of course here daya attend she is here
attend she one of the guys who
contributed to the fan art that we're
gonna be showcasing in the Q & A video
that we're working on hopefully
recording today guys so yeah welcome
everyone let me know what theories you
have for this PV I made a video about it
that you can check out like analyzing it
but there's so much interesting stuff
that we can discuss I I got a few your
messages about some 30 theories I'm
going to be talking about but first I
want to get goes in you and soul macas
first impressions about this HD version
and what were the things that really
stuck stood out to you as interesting as
compared to the low quality where you
saw you can take it first which I missed
your mic is quiet so hello yeah now it's
better
okay yeah like the things that I missed
before I would say are the the fact that
Anya was with Jeremiah in the panned out
shop where the flamingo's were so with
the c2 and more than likely Lelouch on
the camels oh no I think those are the
main details really
and then also DM like I don't know was
it like an engine or rocket or something
that Suzaku was on you know that you
like rides on the kind of crashes into
where the
yes because at first we all thought it
was a train like he was on the train and
trying to attack we jumped out that's
what it appeared like that's what look
like but obviously yeah it's not a train
then something else like maybe a part of
a plane or ship or something yeah by the
way so are you on this court right now
yeah because it I think that's what's
muting your mic it's your mic is is
quieter because I think you're on this
cord so I should exit this code so I
think that that's what might be
happening goes and your your thoughts
what were your biggest takeaways my
biggest takeaway is that's an
interesting question so I loved getting
it in HD we can get a sense of what the
animation is gonna be like which you
know it's it's good as always they
didn't stray too far from what it's like
in the original which is probably a good
thing we don't want them to try to like
do themselves and then do something
over-the-top that no one likes um yeah
I'm like you said Anya that was
interesting um I told Anna Mack some
stuff too that I found interesting but
can't remember right now
so get back to me yeah Anya was
interesting because at first because
she's pink so she blended in with the
flamingos in the low quality version but
in in this version you can finally
actually see her right there beside
orange so that was interesting I also
had a cool mess on this court from sugar
Koon who noticed the Buddha statue that
Cornelia is walking up to in the PV is
similar to the Buddha statues that were
in the Buddhist Obama and I think it's
called they were in Afghanistan they
were carved into mountains into the
stone and they were then destroyed by
the Taliban so you might have heard of
those but he was thinking that perhaps
in this alternate world of coffee yes
they were not destroyed and that she
could actually be in Afghanistan at that
time so I thought that was an
interesting theory yeah there's there's
a cause uh macro on the discord he's
gone into a lot like what he could
possibly think
would be happening with the plot you're
too quiet soul you gotta you gotta fix
it somehow how's that
that still quiet I don't know like did
you try exiting discord completely yeah
why would it be discord man yeah because
sometimes this court takes your also
uses mic and then sometimes it mutes
other things okay that's so quiet yeah
it's so quiet for some reason okay you
sound like this if you hear me now okay
visually telling the whole time all
right is this ASMR didn't a so good no
yes an R is actually the opposite yes
mrs lemons oh you being salad but the
volume being super high alright so I got
I got the pv in front of me and one of
the things was we already knew right
sinusoid you but I do want to see why
they're like explosions of buildings
right the terrorists
looks like terrorist acts but something
that black nights would never do and the
new nightmare frames a purple one I'm
wondering if that's just a recreation of
the original devilish was using or is it
like possibly an enemies one is Allah
Lucius well I had could be that yeah
could it be that Anya did somehow attack
orange since they weren't the same scene
and as a next scene orange being
attacked that's some interesting stuff
right yeah the question again is are
Marianne and Charles really dead or did
their consciousness that somehow I hope
I hope they don't come back yeah or at
least Charles but yelling cuz let's say
Mariana her consciousness will went into
a collective unconscious and then
somehow emerged again and took over Anya
or something but demonicus in the
discourse was talking about the
Knightmare frame and he thought and I
had a few other people say this in the
comments that they thought that it
looked like a combination of the
Lancelot with the shinkiro colors so
people were speculating that it could be
the new zeros nightmare meaning suzaku's
nightmare like a Lancelot but change to
look like zero colors so I want to scare
you guys take on that I think it's
interesting
so Suzaku as
zero kind of has his own his own Mecca
boy died out that's the theory so
interesting so how do you how do you
think that's interesting
oh I'm a louder loud enough no if
anything you're getting more quiet so
seriously what the hell all right well
you got a scream for us to hear you
normal yeah I don't know like maybe try
leaving and coming back in III tried all
right destroy good adam ak in the others
the other interesting parts is now we
know for sure that it's Ribble's and
Miley and Nina or million Nina in the
airport so I'm wondering why they're
traveling and where they going right so
that's going to be interesting to see
because they usually don't leave leave
area 11 and there's one scene that goes
by quick where it seems to be the Guren
traveling with Britannian necklace right
so it's it's interesting to see
nightmare frame so it's interesting to
see how they're gonna be working
together to do something what are they
trying to do in that scene that's going
to be interesting and in the Cornelius
scene we have a so shot of a sword which
could just be background stuff but it's
interesting I wonder why there would be
a sword there and really clear for us to
view it's like some sort of ruins some
important ruins is what I'm getting from
that right it's the ruins are important
and there's a research team like you saw
there's a modern research team using
modern technology they're in front of
Cornelia before the explosion although
some people think it wasn't explosion
that she sees that she sees a nightmare
or landing or something so yeah we don't
know but yeah it's very interesting like
what are they researching and I'm
thinking probably the origins would be
ask something like that but yeah I
really find that interesting um yeah we
have a lot of cool stuff in the chat
people saying they can't hear soul
so yeah after asking to scream I don't
know why no she's just sorting you
saying oh my god okay
that makes us though uncle says nina x
goes in I said it like 50 times and it's
like why man like I'm not a troll I'm
not being a troll man just like you
don't acknowledge trolls animatic like
it's not it was on our other video
saying stuff and you didn't mind he's
trolling now though Oh
Rowling Angela well by the way
Alton who had a theory about the thing
Suzaku is jumping off of and let me just
pull that up can you guys hit me better
now yes now it's good okay then
right well I'll give my ideas while
you're pulling up yeah yeah with
Cornelia I would lean towards a
nightmare arriving as well for that like
wind blown you know blowing her hair
thing definitely I believe she is
researching the gears in order to
uncover the truth behind it so she can
try and clear eupbs name cuz it seems
like that would be her goal
yeah the the nightmare the one that
we've seen that you know people are
thinking you know that's like the
Lancelot but modified and then we
colored yeah
I can see that you know it really does
look like the Lancelot um but yeah I
mean I could imagine yeah he would be
using it you know cuz he used to ride
the Lancelot Suzaku um yeah I don't know
yeah because I have a feeling that um a
BG McCall Lelouch eventually when he
arrives he himself is going to be using
the nightmare so I'm not too sure if
that's like gonna be his nightmare to
Yami I'm not you know I'm not 100%
confident but I can definitely see the
likeness to the Lancelot but that
doesn't mean that like lose himself kind
of had one like made you know so
Lancelot is all like good right advanced
right yeah yeah yeah it's just an
advanced model and obviously time has
passed so any model now would be an
advanced model so it could be like you
know the Lancelot mark 2
we'll mark free or something you know so
you can't exactly ruled out as well what
I was talking about is I don't know if
you guys can see this but she pulled up
like this stuff from like extras about
the copious world and there's this thing
called the SPE mm which was an Angela if
you can see it right oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah house even toys and I will try
they were using for planes mmm
looks like an engine that they were
using for planes but um they don't use
planes much anymore because the Sakura
dite works better with nightmares rather
than airplanes the Sakura is too heavy
for airplanes I think well yeah that was
like a prototype engine for a plane so
she was saying that it looks a lot like
that which is true but I also thought
that it looked like it was on a rail
like a train rail on a single rail yeah
so I thought that it was on a rail and
then it just like spiraled out of
control they went too fast or something
rather than it being just flying
randomly and someone also mentioned that
it could be a guy fun disturber that
someone because orange oranges are all
over Suzaku that he could be in the same
place that Jeremiah is in and that
someone was using the guy found
disturber to mess with orange and it
that's what it was well yeah and he took
it out kind of thing to save orange
wildin yeah yeah yeah potentially
potentially yeah yeah we also got a
question while go from potentially and
they asked about whether Lelouch and
Suzaku are gonna be enemies or are they
gonna be friends the whole season ooh
that I don't know you know because just
in questioning at the end of the day
Susie Susak who's a standpoint was he
gets to get revenge for yuffie and gets
to kill Lelouch so at that point I'm
guessing Lelouch had no knowledge or
awareness that you know he would he
would survive he would live so if he
does come back I mean dies I think that
will still cause
kind of rift between them I mean
obviously who see that okay everything
he's done for a greater good you know
we've had this piece for however long
who thanks to his plan and stuff you
know obviously there were innocence that
died in that process but to then see him
back again he might still feel a bit
cheated you know that he never actually
got that revenge that huge promised so
yeah I feel like it all depends what
Lelouch ends up doing because I'm
guessing the Lelouch is gonna have to
make a big choice either you know appear
in public again never fight his enemies
or leave it to Suzaku like and it'll be
like probably one of the choices Susak
who's gonna be on board with and the
other one he wouldn't so it's gonna be
all like I think Lelouch is actions are
gonna determine how Suzaku acts towards
and like is he gonna do something like I
be on board for a goal that Suzaku
agrees with or if Lelouch is going to
diverge as he often did in the show
which leads to conflict between them it
would be interesting if we over if we
pass that conflict because they kind of
like really melted the whole show and
hopefully like they don't just continue
with the same kind of tropes that
they've been using I'd like to see them
working together because although Suzaku
can suck they're really epic and they
kick ass when they're together so I
think that would be a good combination
so I think if they're together if
they're together the enemy must be a big
deal for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Kubby not only if you have they got the
advantage of you know how great they are
when they work together but you've also
got the advantage of DMO to Lelouch yeah
so you have a lot going on see to also
probably still mortal so so I don't know
what what's going on but I mean the
whole thing before was Lelouch couldn't
defend himself because he went like
athletically like oompa waves his
acoustic Suzaku could be the frontman he
could take on you know fighting whoever
and illusion after hand I could just
like be the brains but now yeah he can
hand back but he doesn't have that fret
of oh my god if they get me because he
can't die you know any injury to stun to
him would then
without back to normal you know so yeah
yeah so in order for this to be
interesting the enemy Lelouch faces is
going to have to be someone that could
potentially kill him somehow right so
I'm sure it's going to be related to the
US power and Bunnell made an interesting
point he says how big of a seemless V
when Nunnally finally finds out the
value she's alive and yeah I agree with
that 100% I was going to be crazy it's
gonna be a crazy reveal like that's one
be one of those attack on Titan right
now he's doing a lot of like building up
two crazy reveals and like I feel like
that'd be one of those things are going
to build up to it it's going to be just
like what and also good bottle by the
way is one of our patrons so thank you
bro for supporting animal or a few of
you guys were asking me about patreon
like where to find it I left a link in
the description if you want to check it
out basically it's if you want to
support us to keep doing this weed stuff
then we we offer you cool rewards real
based on the code geass hierarchy so
yeah if you want to check that out like
in the description and someone else
asked who was this with this dammit i
forget now think I might have lost track
but someone else will stumble if you
think Akito the exiled if you think
actually exile is going to play into
code geass e23 and some people thought
with the camel scene when you zoom in I
thought the hair looked green so I
thought it might be some too but some
people think that it's actually the hair
looks blonde and it actually could be
Layla and Akito in that scene so I
wanted to get you guys a thoughts on
that yeah I think that's that would be
an interesting thing because it's hard
to tell right and whether it's that
light green or yellow from from the
image but that would be interesting if
it was Layla and I could see it for sure
we've seen the possibility of crossover
so I think it would be interesting as
long as they don't take over a
significant portion of the plot I think
it would be fine and I just wanted to
point out that after we can talk about
this after soul maka answers but devil
the rebel what up he asked about code
hunters and whether they could be like
code hunters that are the enemies and
that would make the vampire kind of
parallel that I
talked about before much more clear but
soul maka go well yeah um yeah I
definitely think there's a chance of
them meeting up with Layla and a keto
due to them
joining with the gypsies and traveling
themselves so it's definitely a chance
of meeting up with him but I still think
it is c2 and Lelouch because the last
place they had a headquarters where they
planned out the last steps of the zero
Requiem was in their base in Baghdad
so I'm seniors maybe they're returning
there yeah and the fact that like some
people have like slowed down the frame
and it does look kind of like the card
blown over it's kind of stretching it
but it kind of looks like an illusion
driving yeah I mean it'd be weird they
still yeah look you got these poor folks
know it's like it could be a little a
little tip of the hat to uh you're a
Navy to show us then yeah it's
definitely all English guys yeah it
could be yeah also Enrico said a very
interesting theory he said that in code
year season 3 the villain might be table
kun out for revenge and I think I think
I'll be better for an OVA that would be
like a melodrama that would definitely
be awesome for an OVA the table comes
revenge yeah yeah and says card theory
ha ha ha I love it alright imperialist
opinions says that the Glinda nights
from the odds of the reflection manga
would also exist so they could
potentially come into play and yeah I
think it's very interesting to think
about whether all the reflection ran out
the darkness hakito DXL whether these
would come into play because there are
some cool characters and concepts in
these about the world and so on that I
that I would want to see in season 3 if
done right I wouldn't want to see them
just throw everyone in there and make no
sense but I would like to see like a
keto and Layla I think would be a cool
addition to see the 3 if they do
good way yeah well I'm wild I'd be more
interested actually because I think the
the Glinda Knights themselves would stop
in it you know because like basically
the Black Knights has become like the
unified world please so all the little
factions I guess would have been
disbanded but one thing that was obvious
seven from us and originally he was with
a like a militia group a terrorist group
called peace mark so I'm wondering if
maybe they will play a role into it at
all maybe but all depends it depends
what what they were their goal is you
know cut salmon of doubt is like Lelouch
was in kick-ass band and that others
like your caster but seriously the whole
you know we have to stop the repression
of the people okay mister it's not a
laughing matter
no original Inc says a lot of people
watching more than most Saturdays and I
think it's because the hype with this TV
HD deal for sure the HDTV is is a big
deal and yet the one card thing I don't
know what you guys think but the cart
that we see in the camel scene that's
kind of turned over does look a lot like
the cart at the end of car 2 however
what would that specific are we doing in
the middle of a desert yeah yeah exactly
yeah like that's what point right it got
so do it is for folks and now you know
two camels happen to pass by a yeah this
that's right those what yes what we
listen and we live back and onto these
little things and making cuter theories
about him he's mad crack fairies in yeah
gosh
yeah no but I mean one thing though is
interesting the UM macro from discord
was saying he was saying like you know
the last scene we see in r2 where
they're on the car yes you saying that
that is like no not directly after but
you know it's time after after the
like stuff like that you see saying is
quite some time after yeah like a cow
actually in like Europe area yeah I mean
so they're in Europe already by then you
know traveling down to wherever they're
headed so yeah
sounds interesting that car last a long
time in it was a good car
yeah and Otto said that he thinks that
schneizel might become a puppet for a
new villain yeah schneizel is the kind
of like guy that would be like a to me a
decent side character in r3 because he's
still there he still hates Ellucian
don't even give us that yes power could
potentially be neutralized and yeah so I
think that he could be an interesting
character in r3 but I hope he's not the
main role of him who I don't want I
don't want that at all because I feel
like it's been done right they did a
good back story it went to a good you
know climax between them and that it
concluded well and now if they rehash
that that's gonna be upsetting for me at
least I tell what his mouths gonna come
back that's what is Oh God again
Britannia sighs it's amazing medical
signs healed Amiga oh gosh yeah I see
cookie in the child what's up cookie
girl Bronson horse on den wolf Amelia
aka the cookie BAE is in the chat Finn
rod as well dark ex heart for gone on 15
forgotten not that you will get it right
girl bro don't worry girl bro bro bro
we'll get it right one day and violence
teacher said it's obvious evolution see
two are chillin at our Antarctica with
their penguin bros I like that theory
because there's no basis for it
whatsoever
so don't the best there is a crack it
suspicious that there is no evidence for
it so I think it's plausible
mmm-hmm Ryan says I don't want these old
villains give me something new and
definitely they're definitely gonna need
to get us
new I don't see a way around that and a
Mac I did want to ask you because I
loved season 2 of code geass but you
told me before I don't know if you still
feel this way but you told me that you
prefer season 1 to season 2 and I think
a big part of that was because like they
were trying to do too much make it like
bigger than life kind of thing and now
in season 3 they're gonna need to up the
ante again so do you think there's a
risk of them just going too far with it
I think my biggest problem with season 2
would are - was the whole lelouch versus
- Jacques Cousteau because it kept being
this bromance slash rivalry where
lelouch he would eliminate every other
enemy for the greater good except Suzaku
who he he kept letting him mess up his
plans and that's why I feel like
originally remember that there was that
original script that leaked a while ago
and it was originally Lelouch was
supposed to shoot Suzaku at the end of
r1 and changed that dynamic
however they changed it and went back on
that and then it continued to be his
whole Lelouch
suzaku bromance slash rivalry whereas I
feel like if elucha actually shot him at
the end of our talk he would have
mentally been like that's it I can't
keep letting this guy [ __ ] with me I got
to do what for what what's right for the
greater good even if it means killing my
best friend and kind of I feel like that
would have been a better thing my
problem with art - one of the biggest
ones was that drag between Suzaku versus
Lelouch that relationship I didn't have
a problem with the other stuff the Geass
stopped the mecha stuff I was just was
that part that was kind of uh to me so
let's talk about Australia cuz I don't
think I don't think we're gonna get out
of not talking about Australia here you
know all of our videos we got a mention
at least a few times and Blackfyre wolf
says my theory on Australia is a penal
colony right so that's that's
interesting right but the fact that Matt
wants to go there it makes me think like
in brave new world where there's that
one island where people can still be
kind of how they want to live well
everywhere else you gotta live the same
kind of thing but they keep that there
for specific people
so that they don't have to rail against
the system kind of thing Australia might
be that kind of situation where it's
just this zone where you can kind of do
your own thing and not have to be
obstructed by a different country so
that could be interesting to see what a
straight what's going on Australia and
why do people think it's safer than
other places yeah now get into the
minute which one see the Kazuto kitty
Gaea and we all know your true name
Kirito stop tryna hide says that ask is
green Geass at the end of the PV an
actual Geass and some people believe
it's just a cool thing of the animation
other people think it's a hint that
there's going to different forms of
Geass
so we're not sure and we're just
speculating I think there might be
different forms of Geass but some I
think that it's just an animation yeah
that's one idea but why why would they
do that why I don't get a white green
why why would they just uh I don't know
why would I just be read from the
beginning but I guess I'm green that's
why the last the last two green who's
grown up oh we knew you know there can
be different colored glasses right but
anyway yes an example it could be just
the lights but but they knew they were
gonna like spark theories as soon as
they release that they were like oh yeah
like making it green it's just you can't
not say something about it yeah yeah
yeah yeah guys please I think it's um
interesting because if we didn't have
the blue Geass then we probably would
not necessarily make that connection but
because they show us the blue Geass that
makes us think oh [ __ ] is there a green
yes right so I think it could be
relevant it might not be but either way
like if they if they know if we're
watching season 3 it's all sudden we see
a Geass go green we're gonna go oh holy
[ __ ] like it's gotta be like just insane
just insane
like I don't know if I can even do like
we're doing live reactions for attack on
Titan now I don't even think if we could
do it for go guess I would just like
smash the computers I think the
microphone is like oh [ __ ] I could watch
anymore why did I do that I feel like if
there was that we definitely be way less
looking at the chat and more
like doing anime recon style just
looking at the screen intensely and
being like okay holy oh no oh my god
what is this it's Colin oh my god
that would be our reaction there'd be
little room to actually like serialize
our might be google shot checking at
least not like maybe we would like do
like a live reaction just like watching
it to do like a discussion after but
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't want to know
anything I don't know this world Julia
where Australia like I said in that
video that we made a while ago the image
the Code Geass image from 2009 that
appears to show a scene from season 3
and in this latest PV analysis I talked
a bunch of times about no [ __ ] that I
think a lot of stuff could be happening
in Australia I even came up with a
specific area of Australia where I think
it could be happening because they're
known for sheep they're known for
oranges the landscape looks a lot like
the pv stuff so yeah I think I
personally think Australia is a big deal
because we get the hint that we know
people live there because Mao says we
should go there I have a house there so
you know it's people if there is not
just a penal colony but we also know
that people it's not on the map like
it's not affiliated with anyone so it's
a good place to hide we don't know why
it's like that but it's definitely I
feel relevant and and it would be a good
place to hide it's a huge new continent
where they could go but how you haven't
visited before so yeah I think I think
it's I'm a big Australia conspiracy
theorist myself and I know some people
agree with me some people think I take
it too far but you know Australians man
know there has to be something why is it
untouched why is it why do people feel
safe being there as if it's not going to
be the next target I think there has to
be some reasoning behind all of this
referring to Australia indirectly in the
show there has to be something about it
hmm
yeah and supreme says Geass super then
confirm oh yeah well done well looking I
look forward to that although I did
think the first part of the art oh is
better but but let's hope this this is
not the same case yeah
hopefully not I mean yeah I would really
hate if they started like mooning
characters and things like that you know
just to try and like fit some kind of
basic showing trends or something I mean
I wouldn't know oh but that's right
that's right
it has it's so important that they don't
sacrifice the characters we know them to
be for like some kind of plot to form
them into a specific plot that these
characters would never actually go along
with so knowing the characters in the
writing process will be very important
for to make this like a good show got a
good season
yeah and Couty says animatic aspects
australia that's about a lot pretty much
confirmed curry
yeah that's canon Peter Stratton says
hey guys what's up theatre I've seen you
around before
welcome he'll viens been talking to out
of my fight shun him out yet ELQ is the
dock at or else blah yeah what's up
Hellion oh there's Rick as well
and Colonel Matt was like he said
something he asked didn't Australia look
independence go because he looked gray
whereas everything else was colored so
like I don't even know if it was
independent or like off-limits for some
reason like almost like off the map sort
of thing so yeah I don't know why was
great yeah dunno like Angelo is saying
oh kill Colin goes and cries yes so that
will happen that will happen on the live
reaction if that happens yeah yeah no
yeah they can't kill Cullen
I don't think they'll kill me a main
character like that you never know these
days no with anime and what shows in
general they like to toy with your
emotions no no I don't think no I don't
think I don't think a character like
Colin would die because she's got too
much like stateís in that sense like no
yeah I mean so someone like Oggy I could
see someone like Oggy time yes oh
possibly Valletta no please boogie if
before you like I will step in yeah
there is a family I'll show you it I'll
make sure they're looked out your home
you get to go to boarding school give me
more time alone with the new wife you
know oh I'll keep things keep things
real guys yeah
Varun has a theory and Mitch also said
Mitch in the chat said that maybe
Australia has a hidden thought elevator
that no one knows about and Mitch said
maybe they have some kind of Geass user
or a code bear there that is powerful
and that is keeping people from going to
Australia or invading it colonizing it
and I think that's interesting here
because again we know there was an
ancient civilization we know there's
remnants of that ancient civilization in
the world of Cordia such as the thought
elevators so could it be that in
Australia there is some sort of group of
people that perhaps no more of the
ancient ways so I stronger than what
we've known so far and that's what's
keeping Australia from being colonized
powers or like an actual being there
that is protecting it or is it just as
some people have said spiders and emus
and [ __ ] I don't know I don't know but
it's definitely an interesting concept
okay then old wind really wants me to
acknowledge him saying that the origins
of the Australian population are
prisoners I thought we already know
acknowledge this whole old wind but
since you exist and he says that maybe
it's just like a free land where
everyone's accepted because they just
shipped all the unwanted people there
and yeah maybe has someone who there's
everyone scared of or it's some kind of
neutral ground yeah the only thing about
that is like makes sense but the only
thing about that is why would britannia
being as powerful as they are not
conquer such a huge land with resources
that they can use right yes there was
something really stopped there has to be
a reason there how sir I did
they've got Napoleon there yeah
Napoleon it had has code the point house
code and he's in Australia yeah um yeah
I mean yeah I'm talking about
um situ in Lelouch as well I mean if
they are like heading like towards
Baghdad area or around there there is a
full elevator next to the Caspian Sea so
I like you kind of between yeah this
kind of line in between like Kazakhstan
Turkey kinda area you know so maybe
they're heading over there as well maybe
don't know but yeah yeah again that
would be interesting things assuming
that those are all the thought elevators
and not just all the thought orders
discovered so far
nah that'd be negative says is he the
only one of the things that it was
strange that the song at the end of our
to the final scene the song that's
playing is actually called continued
story and yeah I think that's that's
also a hint to me just like that Easter
Egg yeah it's a hint to me that are
three well seasoned three I know it's
not called are three we just said as a
shortcut but we knew I thought that that
was always planned that was always the
plan and that's why we had these sort of
hints along the way such as continued
story and if we were why if you're
watching a live reaction we also sang
the lyrics translate into English for
the ending and there were other clues
that suggest that there would have been
a continuation
so it's interesting if you look back
even though they could have not done it
and that people would have been like oh
no this doesn't mean anything
I feel like they were just like oh but
if we possibly do it then we have
something to go back on which is
exciting stuff girl bro no one will do
Valletta cosplays no guys should be
doing well in our cosplays I
specifically condemned that idea right
now
if anyone's over to Jamie North you know
what to do make sure to guys make sure
to get a lot of cosplays at anime North
and take pictures with aerovac go Scott
says he didn't see a Bakunin the pv and
he was upset Oh
okay yeah feathers how amazing his hand
somewhere maybe there's a hidden table
cool hint I don't know he was hiding in
the car yeah Lucas trying to tell us
that new the new villain is a kangaroo I
am kangaroo mecha baby a kangaroo
stomach I just jump in and chick as we
know in Aikido they're like horse like
mecca's or guru mecca's just kicking ass
yeah I was actually laughing the one
night when I seen ya when I see the
onion was next to him orange um oh and
Jenny
yeah I was thinking about that you know
the UH the fake video that say the
onions gonna be the new like main
villain yeah I think it may be maybe she
gave okay kid I don't know it yeah like
I mean at the same time probably not at
the same time now this lends a bit of
credibility to that crazy theory I was
thinking like it could even be that like
she's lost it now in it because she's
like finally like realize who she is
whatever cuz like what a majority of her
life like she didn't get to live it cuz
it was like Marian taking over and
spells or whatever so maybe during those
certain times on certain things that
happened in her life that's now GG now
realizes and you know she's lost it that
way or it was a case of Mary Ann or Mary
Ann and Charles some way using the
connection from Miriam's
geese did then invade her body yeah the
sawsan took something it could be
something like that like a continuation
of of what happened last season but
again like I don't think if that happens
that might be a way to start up the plot
but it wouldn't be a way to like they
wouldn't be the main bad guys for the
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean yeah cuz no one would not really no
no no I wrote again violence teacher
says that may be swapped with tamaki is
the father of August child overload and
do not smear my beautiful Valletta with
such lies okay she's not a woman he
would never do that yeah yeah she
definitely rolled stop telling people to
cosplay as maleta
unless those people are beautiful women
in which case go ahead um astral says
that maybe Suzaku or probably Sousa who
has Geass now I would say no because
unless something drastic happens and the
only way to stop it is for Suzaku to get
Geass he's not gonna get it because he
hates Geass you think it's evil
he thinks it's a curse so I don't think
he would willingly get it unless it's
the only way to save him a humanity or
something like that
and one more thing about that so we got
to be careful cuz some people said also
that like callin my guest code somehow
and did the fact is they got a Code
Geass has to be very careful to not make
this like every other character has like
either code or deals like you know you
wanted to maintain at least some kind of
rareness some kind of value but like if
everyone starts having it all of a
sudden the more you have it the less
cool it is the less interesting it is so
I think they'll definitely I hope they
don't go overboard on how many Geass is
and how many codes especially they're
handing out so yeah yeah I mean dude I
mean unfortunately the only thing is for
once someone's got code only someone
with gear symbol files can actually
affect them so you know we've got no
choice in that opinion for threat level
that you know it has to be someone that
is got gas in both eyes unfortunately
yeah yeah and dark X Hart is clarifying
that she's a girl goes and so just in
case you start you know your regular
stuff she's a girl bros or girl bro or
whatever you want to call him oh why
can't why can't we just have like the
whole Pokemon symbols next to your names
that tell me if you're a male or a
female that would be nice but Ryan food
said hit the golden fan boy he said that
he thinks not only would be a good
villain with Geass we had we had a whole
stream on that
craziest stupidest code geass theories
and that was one of them with Nunnally
being the evil villain who knew the
whole time and her plan the whole time
was to become Empress I thought I was a
pretty funny one we'll see we also got
attend she he mentioned remember the
Geass order when the black knights
slaughter all those kids lucky us hmm
yes to us creating what if somebody says
what if one of them survived somehow and
wants revenge and yeah that's the
interest me the most not even
necessarily whether someone survived
from that particular situation but who
are the Geass users out there that we
don't know about are their code bearers
out there that we don't know about
there's just so much that we don't know
and that's the interesting part to me
like there's so much potential and
different options to go so that is why I
think this could be a really great
season if they do it right and they have
the opportunity to do it right yeah well
so long so um Cornelia lives I'll be
happy - yeah we all need our waifu's to
stay alive but the anime dude once you
know that he is a male come on anime do
it come on man you can't just put dude
in your name and expect you to think
you're a guy man what's going on with
that uh yeah I don't know if you guys
saw it because I to ruin in the discord
when like me after Michael discussing
about you know the PV and stuff she
actually found a picture of the
niggerand and it looks like he's got a
jaw attachment on it son
hey what a drill a golden drill oh
that's mr. heavens oh that was a very
cool thing to be honest if they created
something like that no yeah it's a
picture but it's like it's like a non
unofficial it's official image but it's
not like from a season it's like a
promotional image I think right yeah I
don't know there's two images because
there's one when you see tonight mares
you know going through the trees you can
see hopefully then yes and then big but
then there's another picture which is
the promotion
image of her stood there with rock star
and oh man someone else I can't remember
who I see it there with the drove the
actual Joel you can see it clearly
visible in it so but that second image
is not from a season it's like a just a
promotional image yeah yeah I want I
gotta see that no well I mean in the PV
when when the nightmares a guy in foody
trees you can partially see that you can
see it does look like a drill so yeah
she saw me this yeah that picture and I
definitely agree that that is an
interesting point
Christian is here what up bro for what
up floor and not too fired up is here
too I haven't seen him yet here um
someone's Luka mentioned the thing where
the Geass Chancellor seems to allow
Lelouch to give another command to the
same person so when we see the surely
seen of her dying after the Gita's
cancers used the command seems to be
taking effect except she's already too
far gone like she's dying
physically however if her eyes start
glowing like telling us that it's
working so he thinks it might be a plot
point
Geass cancer along whoosh to use Geass
on the same person there could be an
interesting plot point in the future
that can be a drill is cool I I can't
wait one of my favorite parts is gonna
be seeing how they create new technology
and how they get creative with that I
enjoy seeing that I wonder if it uses
the microwave thing is well with the
drill the microwave oh yeah yeah yeah I
think it would be cool if they combined
the two right now that would be so good
oh my god right there I'll be so
overpowered flick I thought when you
said the microwave thing I'm like is he
talking about Stein's Kate like what is
he like thought I might want to go as
well yeah yelling we're gonna have new
nightmares it's gonna be a very
interesting aspect of it for sure
one thing that I'm also thinking about
is I don't know if we discussed this but
why do you
that in the PV so the scene right before
we see Cornelia Cornelia I think she's
too much too much tuned there for me but
very attractive woman who um repeated
Cornelia Cornelia we know Valletta we
know Valera is you know waifu material
beneath the surface but the question is
uh I don't think Cornelia is it
synthetic coz what kind of act with her
with her person she loves
what's-his-name
what's the dude's name her Knights which
is always nice to forget like what would
a good one
gilberto something like Ellis yeah kill
something kill freaka Guildford psycho
hood sauna field person large but the
way I was gonna say is why you guys
think that it appeared like the Guren
was fighting alongside the Britannia and
purple nightmares well because the one
in it yeah exactly you about now all
together yeah if unified why that's why
I'm gonna go be go kill Ford no one
Guildford yeah that's Guildford
Guildford that's it okay yeah Gilbert go
stuff how that would make it so much
less cool I'm sorry to everyone called
Gilbert Gilbert I love you Anna max name
is Gilbert confirmed so tell people my
real name dude emo Spider Man aka
Gilbert aka wannabe Goza grow from the
best son okay you're even I was done in
your name but it was funny when someone
combined her names what was it like it
was today it was like goes and Adam back
or something goes and back someone up
goes the Mac I wasn't asked by a
Cornelia definitely beautiful woman okay
soul just linked me an image god knows
what this is gonna be okay oh good its
to do it what cousin said oh yes Stein's
Geass that's funny
oh man I gotta sleep I can see it too or
no yeah just click it don't worry it's
not it's not usual so luckily we trying
to say oh that's so cute
that's nice and I think this this goes
all together just because Curtis is such
a cute character and see - in this
position is cool thank you
girl bro for saying Anna Mac number one
um yeah people went wild over this whole
Gilbert thing I love it
Gilbert you know man or you Bertha not
now give it kill ducked my night Mitch
says maybe someone in Australia is
creating like a secret group that could
counter Britannia and that is like a
secret group for sure is interesting
because in that world more and more
people are learning about yeah so we
have the Euro Pia learning about heels
through Laila right and Aikido and so in
the future we know that Geass is going
to be a thing right because um people
know that it's out there it's a huge
weapon in the hands of the Britannian so
far but they will all want it to fight
against the pertinence wars are still
happening there like right now we think
with the zero Requiem its peace but as
I've always said on these streams and
whenever people talk to me about it
I don't think the zero record will hold
up because all these rival nations want
their own piece of the pie so for them
all to follow the black knights and to
have the black knights as their only
military I never thought that would last
so I think that definitely there's gotta
be secret groups especially because the
zero Requiem is supposed to be the
official thing at the Black Knights are
officially attacking you know defending
the world whatever there's gonna be
secret groups of influential people
preparing to fight back against the
Black Knights and assert their own
dominance right so I think that that is
definitely a possibility having like
secret groups maybe Glinda Knights
coming into play again maybe not but
maybe it'll be interest yeah it'll be
interesting to see how now that
they go they have power if the Black
Knights will somehow become corrupt or
if they'll just not be able to control
how much power they have
I know animatic is in to those kinds of
plot twists from reading his novel so
that's gonna be interesting to see no
spoilers for my novel why guys it's
really good as soon as it's kept publish
everyone needs to buy 10 copies it's
silk
so you can give to all your friend no
but Luca said something that I didn't
like let's read this and think about it
because I haven't talked about this
he says the statue of Cornelia that
Cornelia approaches looks like the one
that had its upper head smashed and a
butterfly on its nose during the
flashback of Ritu and Charles talking
about their pact to kill God now this is
something I noticed is this is this true
yeah I had we'd have to go back there's
no way I can remember to count let me
enter mine me when someone comes up with
a fat memory yes it's exactly the same
yes uh yeah no episode was that though
episode was that when there the
flashlight was about 18 you look at you
from which number episode that is yeah
cuz I could check it real quick right
now forgotten man says she'll buy 100 of
your novels Animax so we got a holder to
that yeah well don't worry no worry girl
bro we'll do business all Texas will be
reading my book night of the Watchers
look out for that Oh
pipes are the hype is real man right
after all the code geass code yeah
seasons come out then adamak will just
drop this book and it would be the next
time hopefully sooner ha ha yeah
hopefully sooner I don't know agents
right now so it all depends on when I
get an acceptance and then it's
happening maybe I'll keep you guys
posted of course here on the channel so
stay tuned I'll give you five minutes
Luka you work our episode us or check it
flashback I think episode 18 is longer
sir no Phyllis Kahn against by the way a
Mitch says that he thinks that maybe the
statue is guarding the Cornelius welcome
to is guarding an empty ins to the to a
thought elevator and perhaps they're
blowing it up in order to blow up like
order to find the fall elevator which is
interesting because we know that there
is tall elevators in Asia right and this
look that looks like Asian architecture
and Athol elevator is definitely
something that you would wanna research
so that is that being related to a
elevator i 100% thing is possible what
happens if like the cyllage get blown up
though daniel mac any theory is like
lucas is episode 39
adamak what auto elevators get blown up
what happens candidly anymore like
that's the thing maybe someone wants to
destroy the connection between the world
of see and the real world yeah that's
the thing what happens if you destroy
however first of all can you destroy it
with conventional weapons second well if
you do what happens does it destroy sees
world does it destroy the connection
with sees rule doesn't do nothing at all
as long as you use another thought
elevator we annoy here and assume I
assume it would the see world would be
able to grip like still impact the real
world but the real world would not be
able to get to sees world but who knows
yeah and and Kristen says that she hopes
it's good really good and so do we
for sure yeah I hope it I hope it's like
really goldrush potential well obviously
to my top three anime of all time so
much potential with that world that they
set up and that's what makes a great
agreement they set up the kind of world
that is really has so many options of
potential which means that there's
plenty of room to make more stories and
you have a great third season so yeah
definitely fingers crossed and I'm gonna
be optimistic sold you said you wanted
to say something no no no just so that
like says it
episode finance I'm just trying to get
the episode Friday night now and take a
look and see what says so I believe this
episode 14 yeah I look forward to seeing
how all the temples look differently to
where they are in the real world
yeah because I don't think a Buddha
statue it'd be in front of all of them
right it has to be a specific one yeah
I'm guessing it would be different based
on the culture that it's and I got a
thought because remember the thought
light emitters were created long ago no
one even remembers when so I'm guessing
that you know some people would see
these things and be like whoa this is
ten plus four God kind of thing
something powerful so that they could
perhaps erect newer temples around them
and relating it to their own religion
right
yeah there's no way we cannot deal with
the world to see in the next season
oh I feel like it's just setting up
right for it know that that statue
that's not she looks European um it
looks like they're in down the middle
Europe somewhere and stuff that's not
true this at the beginning of a episode
for me all right
the European versus Buddha confirms oh
yes so Seoul says that the statue look
at the your Tamil the beginning of our
episode working our - he thinks that
it's more a European style architecture
meaning that it would be a different
statute yeah yeah like it's like you
know I kind of like the Greek statues
are and stuff you know and they have
like they have the rope kind of the same
in it like the Roman stuff oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean and so yeah it
looks more like that because the setting
that they're in you can see like a
European kind of castle in the
background and stuff like that obviously
that would be nowhere near any kind of
oriental setting you know so yeah that's
a fair point that's a fair point
Arthur was going crazy into chat someone
I think someone said something that she
knows is not right so she's just like
why in the Norse versus Buddha according
to fin rod Angelo says that
he thinks religion was used as the cover
for the world of see and yeah because we
know that there's like a church or Geass
that we see with the nun and a situ so
it's like I feel like they would
definitely use religions and stuff like
that to combine it with Jesus in order
to get people to you know accept yes or
if they know about it to accept it or to
keep it hidden because obviously imagine
our world it was suddenly revealed that
there was such a thing as Geass power
that only certain people had people
would panic they would be afraid so who
is this are they controlling me we have
to get rid of these people so they would
definitely use all sorts of tactics to
kind of calm people down or to make them
believe that these are like gods or like
chosen people prophets or something or
just to keep it hidden right so I think
that in the different parts of the world
different religious orders and stuff
would use everything they could to keep
it in and kind of like an attack on
Titan you have the the wall Church like
the Church of the wall that is keeping a
lot of secrets in order to stop people
from panicking yeah that makes sense and
at the same time they could have just
evolved on its own right they're also
they all know that there's something
like SeaWorld something like God out
there and they all just do their own
cultural kind of scenarios cultural
experiences and they create their own
kind of God from it yeah because the
assumption were going on guys is that
the ancient civilization known as the
ragnar is created this before modern
humans existed so basically it wasn't
like one Church of geass that existed
since the Rogner is today humans in
different parts of the world
discovering the ancient civilizations
remnants started kind of coming up with
their own beliefs to explain what this
was that's at least my belief and that's
why we see the different types of
architectures the Buddhist statue the
European statue it's telling us that in
different parts of the world that these
thought elevators exist this ancient
civilization was influential and how
these different cultures exist today are
dealing with it and trying to understand
it okay yeah yeah just like I have like
certain religions and still work on the
same kind of premise
but then also like I got like
Christianity Islam and Judaism yeah and
by the way our boy Gilgamesh has arrived
another one of our patrons what's up bro
glad to have you here yeah welcome bro
and time to catch the ending at least
but we had good discussion today for
sure any other things you guys saw from
the PV that you want to discuss letting
me know in the chat um yeah like I said
the orange stuff the guy biggest
takeaways were oranges around suzaku
then I didn't figure out at first
anja uh the closeup of the camel stuck
where it clearly looks like a girl with
long hair did I feel like is greener
some people says blondish either way
interesting and the definite drill the
drill if it is cuz I didn't even see it
but if if there's a drill on the garand
mark - that's huge I think as well well
depending on how good the drill is still
man like that's that's big like that's
something I gave that would get me
psyched and the other thing would be I
really do wonder why rebels and them are
in the air PR where are they traveling -
I think that's very important for the
plot so I I look forward to seeing why
they're in an airport you know an author
who says you will discuss this stuff
more in the discord so yeah guys if you
want to join the discord link is in the
description we have a special animated
series of chatroom in there just for
theories to discuss we also have a code
geass room for just going yeah stuff so
like if you like this kind of stuff and
you want to do it more than once a week
like we do feel free to join the discord
Oh almost a thousand thirty members
right now so well over a thousand and I
am yeah so what were you saying there
goes and about the airport yeah I had
some someone I forget not who it might
have been sugar who I'm not a hundred
cetera message me a while ago saying the
airport scene might be in Australia or
them traveling to Australia yeah I know
Australia again and even showed me some
pictures of the Brisbane
Airport that looked very similar to that
Airport scene so I don't know guys
I don't know yeah but unlike even
airports like I feel like they look
alike by the at its that could be who
knows if it went really closely you
could be like you can see on the floor
it's written Australia [ __ ]
you have to zoom in really closely
though and I wonder what the scene with
um Suzaku clearly and zeros outfit like
going in that steam over those steam
pipes like I will not remember seeing
something like that before yeah yeah it
look like a factory of some sort or
something I mean maybe there's like
maybe is like a terrorist faction and
maybe like there's a factory or
warehouse around that kind of industrial
looking area and they're hiding out
there plotting and you know who's going
in there to intercept to whatever
possibly and you know what like when
there's a shot before that new mecha
appears before the new nightmare frame
appears there's a shot in like a very
green place and then there's destruction
of the mecha Falls that does seem kind
to remind me of when Jacques was running
so it could not be Suzaku in the
Knightmare frame we'll see could be the
Knightmare frame trying to destroy
Suzaku because they're both very green
locations the anime XD says that do we
think that the marks on the damage marks
on the zero mask look like bullet holes
and I I thought I don't know if if the
mask is bulletproof then that could look
like bullets hitting it but not piercing
through because definitely looks like
yeah I'm looking at it right now
definitely looks like could be bullets
for sure yeah like but they're not
pierced through so it's not hole so no
dentin yeah it's dented so if we assume
that the mask has been made bulletproof
and it has to be bullets yeah that's
that's I think that's the smartest
assumption I don't see what else it
could be
yeah and uh Hutton she asked
how would how do we think lelouch would
make himself public again would he come
out as the enemy of the world nor would
he come out as a hero
and I think that he should come he would
not come back to life like you know tell
me was alive unless he really had to and
I'm thinking that the only way we he had
to would be to fight against the greater
evil so my thing is that he would come
out of the shadows in order to fight
against the greater evil
rather than pretend to be the bad guy
himself so you know I don't think he
should come out at all because there's
too much to explain even if light even
if I came out yeah I mean I'm supposed
to be dead ya say laughter my family off
that you have faked my own death of God
yeah and this is just my family yeah we
let alone the rest of the world
yeah right and then two years later say
I didn't turn up because you know
someone was there endangering my family
whatever yeah there's so a lot of
explaining to do hearing people ain't
just gonna accepting oh yeah okay no
it's okay yeah you saved us
straightaway they're good where the [ __ ]
have you been
well you know we are costly instead I
guess yeah it's very ya know cuz I mean
there's a lot of people who don't care
for him as a person because they don't
know him as a person the only known as
the tyrant yeah I mean so you know
they're not going to be as um like
reluctant talks questions or as
accepting of him yeah as like Colin or
um Tojo or anyone else yeah I mean they
don't know any other bags no exactly
yeah I think that's a good one my
goodness is he going to reveal himself
publicly at all that's a good point and
sugar Kuhn is in here what's up bro I
mentioned you earlier in the stream
because of the stuff you sent me on
discord the theory stuff racists asked
to post the party the time of the party
or discord party tomorrow it's basically
gonna be going on all day radius I'm
gonna be just chilling on this core
pretty much all day we're gonna have
some events just hanging out it's not
going to be anything like comment a
specific time just come hang out it's
gonna be a fun time goals that is going
to make an appearance I invited all the
Red Cafe crew to come I think most
we'll make an appearance so yeah it'll
be just like an all-day type fun come
whenever you can for Sunday oh it's
gonna be big and it's gonna be lit come
with me des hype agreed i'll agreed my
friend and there will even be blade
Ultra says wait what is season 3 coming
out it is coming out the sequence coming
up we just don't know when there is no
release date yet but we just a a PV that
was leaked back in the summer and poor
quality was recently leaked in HD so in
this stream we've been looking at hints
that we have in the PV PV reading
preview or teaser trailer about Cody s
season 3 and what what we can kind of
come up with for potential plot based on
the clues in that PV there was someone
else that said something interest yeah
goes on will be on discord like Ryan
says so not all day like adamak but I
will be there
so we gotta we hit mm we got to do it
somebody bring beers for the party yeah
BYOB people yeah black fire wolf is
talking about the figure that's climbing
up those pipes and yet definitely I
would say that's like Suzaku in there
because he's he's the craziest Letta guy
spins aqua doing all this gymnastic [ __ ]
Lelouch can do that'll get started from
running so definitely I would not think
that's a look that could easily be like
the night and then the morning after
that's when like the mask is found on
the beach yeah yeah yeah yeah who's like
he tries to intercept them but you know
they had far too much firepower I'm
getting imagine what happens now when
the whole world sees that zero has been
defeated right because I'm guessing
these people want to like attack zero
show show their power disorganization
and now you have that zero mask on the
beach shows that he did lose his mask
who's being shot at so clearly like that
would be interesting to see how the
world
x20 their savior being defeated by
somebody that'll be interesting yeah
rosemarie cat said something she said
did you know that the gear symbol is a
crane like the wishes that they keep
talking about
and yet the gear symbol is definitely
some kind of bird and it could
definitely be a crane and that's an
interesting point because cranes and
wishes are mentioning the show and of
course Geass is supposed to fulfill your
greatest wish right so it's definitely a
cool connection that you made there I
like that a lot Rosemarie Gilgamesh says
some Colin plot yeah we got we got a
some of that we got a some that
oh man I mean my Valletta Colin and
Cornelia plot man Valletta is just gonna
be like do you not even let us stuff is
just gonna be her with a kid man relax
she's out of money no is that what you
said like I don't think they'll be like
fan servicing her too much she's
probably just gonna have a kid in her
hand they're just gonna be like hey it's
cold Geass bro don't don't bet on that
Kolka Joe gaming says that he thinks
that the zero mass might have like
barnacles on his tongue might have been
just damaged in the water depending on
how long it was there and yet to me it
looks like damage from a fight but it
does also depend on how long it's been
there yeah cuz it like if you look at it
closely it has a lot of whole like shape
dance like you know like a circle shape
dance repeatedly so it would be weird if
they got all that just from hitting into
rocks and stuff right so it would seem
it would seem that there were shots
fired at it shots fired
Oh some kind of a heat damage yeah yeah
that's Chuck yeah for sure knowing what
we know definitely and see a lot of
people that you are saying they want
some see to plot as well they think c2
is best girl so yeah I think c2
lower-body plot is always best c2
plotters isn't general good I wasn't you
I want some cheese Clint plot yeah yeah
now c2 like again you got a lot of
there's nothing to not a lot about say
to yeah I really wonder whether we're
gonna have cheese cooling table Quinn
and
those little references in the sequel I
hope we will because we're gonna go
crazy for every little thing well I
don't because it all depends on how much
the creators are actually paying
attention to what the fans like in the
show because to them those are minor
details you may wage right now well well
table can may no longer be in it because
it will depends cuz I mean they're not
gonna be in the school anymore I
shouldn't think yeah hopefully I mean
they might hopefully they're not too
much like Dragon Ball super and just
kind of writing fanfiction right though
hopefully they they have their own like
kind of idea where they're going and
they're not just like listening too much
to the community and just being like all
right here's your fanfic here here's
your fan fake here well I wanted to
listen to me not the whole community but
like I love them it was between yeah I
think it just it's it's a it's a line
you have to walk a fine line where you
don't want to be too too serving the
fans too much so I guess overboard and
it's just yes mean accuse everybody in
the end you don't actually please
anybody you create a stupid product so
if I take strike a good balance between
that yeah author who says if 1000 cranes
equals a wish coming true
then do you think that a Geass might
require being a guessing 1000 people
before you get a double Geass in both
eyes I don't know I think that's
probably just a coincidence because it's
hard to like you know when do you give
us a thousand people does four-mile
everybody count that he whose minds he
reads and stuff like that right so I
think that's probably just a coincidence
but one thousand number I don't think
there's a connection per se but you know
that's my opinion yeah yeah that's Plus
as well and he has to head out to work
but he says by and he hopes that there's
gonna be lettuce fanservice for me in
season three
thank you bro and that's what is that I
gotta go I wish you a lot of a lot of
fan service peace out it's like adamak
you desperate for that [ __ ] man you
desperate I hope you get what you need
you get your fix it's been too long
man's for ten years man we all look
right now I got soul I got soul he gets
me Edward yeah yeah they do some like
black market underground stuff together
it's you know I don't know about it well
as he still not seen it
oh you said it okay yeah
so I wanted to make that picture the
thumbnail convinced him we will see how
a little burning and I'll decide what
what will be a thumb because he's
buttered that he's not in the thumbnail
but man come on
so we will see you will see I will test
out different things I don't figure
don't need to do one few goes in as oh
yes yes there god yes for the next video
goes it out the work man
no bye and also mock if you could that
would be nice for the next you'll
because Marcus forward yeah do your best
like I'll keep that one red no yeah I'll
keep that in mind I'll keep that we only
am in glory and honor we don't pay any
money
remember that yeah yeah okay who and I
got bills yeah I got bills hey boy of
course no hey I've gotta pay the bill
he's got mouths to feed man he's yeah
yeah I'm on the little oh yeah by the
way guys Mackel not our boy Mackel not
right now is streaming on Twitch a
tournament a gaming tournament with rude
devil and a bunch of people so I'm gonna
after this dream head out there for a
bit to chill and then into this court
because on our discovery are we doing
like karaoke and all this fun stuff so
be sure to I'll live I left the link in
the description both to the discord and
to max channel at which channel if you
want to go and check it out max a great
guy anything else you guys want to say
before we call it a day on this stream
goes in or soul nothing much stuff is
looking up and apparently as Anna Mac
said there might be some news about Kogi
at season 3 during anime North so like
the end of May coming out in Japan so
that would be exciting things are
looking hyped right now on the internet
I just hope it doesn't like they keep
giving us little by little so the hype
stays real and thanks for supporting us
all the way through like this whole year
and and some of you were there before so
we appreciate it you know awesome
community guys thank you all for coming
here regularly China with us we have
such a blast doing it always including
stole mark our boy who I think you've
been here since December on the channel
bro me uh yeah I probably only changed
since December yen and I joined the
discord early January I believe yeah
that's when we made it it wasn't even me
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah so yeah yeah I
don't did this construe it and pretty
much yeah yeah yeah so I see I remember
when when you came to the channel so I
remember I remember the guy that says
I'm a code geass fan of hentai artists
yeah oh yeah yeah I remember to its
compact it's that is very noticeable in
it I mean there's not many of us out
there that would do that so that was
like make mental note hey keep this guy
taking on court so much doesn't pay the
bills doesn't fail in rows or guy I hope
it helps um yeah now I wanted to become
like the full-time thing
currently I've made a good contact food
at discord actually a mega he's into
game programming so I'm be working with
him to make a visual novel very hot with
very glass that's gonna be interesting
once once I saw it and stuff then yeah
definitely yeah like the discord has
been a great resource for many people we
met some cool people we you know got
together uh people doing projects
together so yeah it's a very very fun
thing very fun like definitely way more
than I could have expected in terms of
creating this community so it's been
amazing a few people are asking if Geass
expires if the command expires after the
the person that gave them the command
dies and first of all like we know
illusion died so his Geass would on
Suzaku would still technically be the
live thing would still be there I don't
know is there any other examples of
someone dying in them the Geass command
still be active active yeah um
I don't know I don't know uh Yami cuz
you could say yeah with Nunnally you
know with Charles diet but the thing is
with that scene when we see her she then
breaks out of it you know cause she
opens our eyes by me that doesn't rule
out the memories ain't still affected
it just means yeah she opened the eyes
because I mean she was still like
confined to the wheelchair whatever
that's just because like the muscles
weakened over time I don't know but um
yeah yeah it could also be that her
memories are still partly like hazy and
affected with what actually happened cuz
yeah you know because the geass are
different to like some of them are just
for a little while like rolos right some
of them are pretty like you have a
permanent effect some of them expire
after a while so yeah it's an
interesting interesting thing to think
about I'm not 102 but either way we know
Lelouch is not dead so I feel like we
might see Sousa who with his command
live yeah I think so
thanks hon Tarun asked is there hope for
Milli x rebel and I think rebel hope so
I don't know if there is yeah yeah I
don't know by but iTunes convinced me
that there could be a chance you know
that they can actually get together and
Millie in Millie fashion just trolling
people eventually showing a hand that
then has the ring on it um signifying
obviously their engagement or marriage
or whether you know it feels so good for
rules yeah finally finally you go in
there like finally he was there from day
one they were serving ten years bro do
you yeah yeah but yeah sounds good guys
great discussion again as always thank
you soul for joining us and goes in as
well I know how close you are
well thanks for respect how days were
grossly not doing any your presence on
nothing but love right yeah of course
everyone in the chat thank you so much
for coming again and hanging out next
week we'll be doing the stream too if
there's no big news we might just do the
rewatch again but either way Cody as
content on this channel will is here to
stay because we love it and other
content called yes and other popular
anime love yeah and of course we do the
weekly news we do all the big news we
make videos on it and allyce's that kind
of stuff so of course if you're new to
the channel subscribe and yeah stay
tuned for more and until next time see
ya see a side blows bang bang